alors maintenant on va voir que
l'interview psy n'est pas seulement
réservé aux filles puisque données
puisque vous allez en est la victime je
suis jamais bon point qui saignait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a bougé mais voilà je suis assez
grand à l'udm comme seka school
l'a pas touché jacques après l'émission
plus quoi ça venait du fait du cheval ou
quoi
les délateurs faut faire rigueur alors
que guillaume canet on va voir
maintenant que l'interview psy n'est pas
seulement réservé aux filles puisque
voulu en être la victime
du
[Musique]
j'ai mal chauffé un regard je regarde
bien alors vous connaissez le principe
est ce que vous êtes mito quand ça
m'arrange enfin parano ouais ouais
skeezo
non
grâce à ce qu'ils jouent ouais non non
non non mais
elle me l'a fait avant
la regard incroyable ne me regardez pas
voilà je vous demande un truc faites-le
pour ma femme mes enfants et j'ai de la
famille séris gentil arrêté de me
regarder voilà bien si si regardez moi
maso
maso non pas du tout ma zone
non peut-être aurait peut-être des fois
j'aime bien me faire du mal mais
psychologiquement physiquement non non
je fus du monde non non les bougies tout
cela non non
c'est ado non non plus loin sous dos non
plus
exhibo
ouais
non non c'est vrai mais mais en privé
ouais mais c'est quand vous êtes tout
seul c'est pas tout ça
c'est vraiment ma télé je rejoigne m
non non non mais avec des proches en
fait je m'en rends compte que j'aime
bien me montrer mon cul tout ça ouais
fetisov êtes fétiche au nom
sait pas très bien si ça j'aime c'est
vrai le harass à l'adresse et le
porno et cassettes pornos ouais bah
ouais bon comme tout le monde j'aime
bien écouter que lass
est ce que vous êtes vibro non non on va
quoi vibro c'est quoi les grosses et le
space mountain
gens qui aiment les films utilisés des
vibromasseurs
est ce que vous êtes trio
non non non je vais essayer si bon si
vous appelez tissu mais les jeunes
filles et garçons aux deux garçons une
fille non de finir son nom mais c'était
très longtemps mais voilà mais avec ce
fini tout ça alcoolo
non
non j'aime bien boire un coup comme
monde quoi non je me lève pas avec le
102 matin pétards d'eau oui est ce que
vous êtes kadéos oui mais non non c'est
sincèrement ils savent que j'aime
beaucoup un bon séjour marseillais sait
chanter file dans ta loge pas facile
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux